[Musica]
ciao ragazzi poi tornati in una puntata
di cucina buttata quella che vedete oggi
è una collaborazione con ferrari gran
mix che abbiamo deciso di omaggiare con
una ricetta mai vista prima
oggi infatti faremo un profiterol salato
ripieno di formaggio e cosparso di
formaggio stiamo trasformando il dolce
il salato rendita per fare i bignè e
avremo bisogno di 130 grammi di farina
infinito 100 g di burro 210 grammi di
muffa 200 millilitri di lacrime al 5
grammi di zucchero e un pizzico di
cumulo oggi noi siamo demiurghi siamo
reni da quello che toccheremo grazie a
questo prodotto lo trasformeremo da
dolce al salato da normale torta oro
volete anche voi essere re mida allora
la vostra mano può fare un miracolo
ragazze o con un solo dito cliccare sul
pulsante iscriviti e trasformare la mia
giornata in oro il mio cane non mangia
da giorni se anche tu vuoi aiutare
questa la foto del mio cane possiamo
averlo più deperito prenderne un'altra
metti anche tu un click
non ti costa nulla aiuta molto a tornare
a sorridere
stiamo girando il giorno del compleanno
della linea e invece di essere felice è
qui a lavorare guardate una donna che ha
36 anni ha perso tutto mettete un like
per la vigna anche voi avete mai visto
immagini più triste sta in mezzo dal tuo
paio e non ha più un sogno con sé quello
sguardo tirato per la vita gioia che
volete capito auguri auguri auguri
infelice
gli ultimi mesi sembra uno scemo no
sembra quella quale non dareste niente
nella vita e in parte questa ragione ma
non quando si tratta di pigna iniziamo
subito ragazzi quindi a fare la crema su
tagliamo a crema lucia caos e cioè
l'impasto su l'impasto su se non l'avete
mai fatto e divertentissimo perché
tendenzialmente non sporcate niente
prendiamo il burro e iniziò a tagliarlo
a quadretti aggiungo l'acqua un pizzico
di cumulo e lo zucchero lo zucchero
accendo ed iniziò a sciogliere
lentamente tutto quanto attendo attento
e attendo soprattutto e poi e tion diamo
la fatina tutta quanta insieme tutta pam
così senza paura di gruppi senza paura
di niente
a testa alta come re mida che potreste
essere anche voi comunque posso dirti
una cosa un po vera la venia mettetevi
una mano sul cuore lasciate un commento
di auguri alla linea un pensiero carino
perché noi non abbiamo più nulla
tanti auguri e la venia sta bollendo
quindi subito buttate tutta la farina
dentro e iniziate a girare ragazzi gira
le girate tirare ingloberà tutto quanto
il che il barile che si stacca
perfettamente le bordi interessantissimo
questo procedimento ha fatto contro
tempo che farà shocks conosciamo un
secondino a riposare prendiamo il
composto spendiamo ovviamente la fiamma
e aggiungiamo un uovo alla volta mi
raccomando naga sono 210 g io siccome è
un professionista faccio un po occhio
non corporate e quelle perfettamente
incorporato aggiungere quello dopo
finché non arriverete a questa
consistenza una crema bella
ragazzi che possiamo iniziare a sbattere
sulla teglia armiamoci di sac à poche e
andiamo a riempirla con la nostra casta
enrico wine show ma adesso questa è una
pasta
no è diventata improvvisamente crema
pasticcera la prendete in mano e
rigirate qua pugno dentro è la verità
pazzesco sembra che abbia fatto altro
nella vita no infilo il cucchiaio e
contro la mano lo sbatto come se la
prendesse in mano come questo è il
metodo condiviso i ragazzi non riempiamo
la troppo tutto quanto questo trucchetto
di verbania d'acqua ricompatti sto
togliendo tutti quanti il perù litio gli
dà fastidio è bruttino 180 gradi questi
sono un pochino più piccolini quindi io
li cucinò per una ventina di minuti
prima da controllare
fra poco
[Musica]
hai qualcosa da dire
posso dirlo se il king dei vini è grazie
non mi serve sentire altro che adesso
che facciamo altri ma non vi faremo
vedere
passiamo adesso al ripieno per il
ripieno avremmo bisogno di un 200 g di
gray mix classico ferrari sponsor di
questo video o sublime grattugiato
fresco gusto equilibrato un mixologist
l'ha creato mezzo litro di latte 50 g di
farina infinito 50 g di burro o
guanciale e del pepe bianco come ho
detto che ci sarà questa crema mousse di
formaggio e delle piccolissime pepite di
guanciale togliamo al volo la cotenna
che si affaccia vari chirurgo perché tu
non hai idea di come funzioni questo
prodotto che fa capire che non sei
niente
la tua ignoranza in materia suina mi
annichilisce creiamo dei cubetti vi
belli piccoli perché devono entrare
dentro il biglietto troppo spesso che
cosa il tuo ego qui io vedo solo una
cosa che più che spessa ingombrante the
car sharing non giovano paper motiva
mente ingombrante e inutile che cerchi
farmi cascare in fallo pure farmi
arrivare addosso a fuoco bassissimo
bruciate perché
proprio in questo modo andare un pochino
a caramellare quasi e quando il grasso
comincia a salire alzate leggermente la
fiamma in modo proprio da quasi cannes
dirlo mi raccomando ragazzi stateci
dietro col fatto che è così minuscolo
del verde lo prendiamo e lo mettiamo da
parte come lo metti poi dentro le
forbici da sminuzzare al modello uniamo
alla moussa poi con la saga potion
andiamo a riempire ma si bloccano di
fare il momento pare sarà come ho fatto
io un giorno cioè la brulla passiamo a
questo punto alla crema di formaggio
fatta con ferrari gran mix ricordiamo un
formaggio creato proprio da un
mixologist che è riuscito a incorporare
all'interno di questa deliziosa ponder
ben tre formaggi diversi al fine di
creare un equilibrio di sapori unico un
equilibrio che ne andremo sfruttare per
la nostra crema della nostra falsa per
la nostra culata di gioia su questo
profittevole e formaggi che sono il
grana padano il parmigiano reggiano
elementale svizzero per primo e quando
troviamo in lastre e cominciano a
scaldare mi raccomando non deve
raggiungere il bollore burro lo facciamo
sciogliere è come prima
farina e girate ragazzi di nuovo questo
è un richiedo show non proprio non
facciamola frustate e lo aggiungiamo al
latte tiepido guardai fatta contro il
presepio messo
questo tempo ci abbiamo messo due
secondi a questo punto il protagonista
della nostra ricetta va aggiunto a
questa crema di latte la togliamo dal
fuoco due sacchetti mia quando lavorate
da ben in modo da incorporare aria e
rende la bella morbida spumosa pazzesca
inglobare ragazzi chi è cosa mi dice che
è cosa mi dice che è cosa mi dici chi è
perfetto pratica di una frusta
mamma mia ragazzi la vedi come ariosa e
andiamo ad aggiungere il nostro francia
le finemente tritato ragazzino suoniamo
bocchettone largo della sac à poche
perché sennò vi si blocca tutto quanto e
riempiamo con il composto che andiamo a
infilare nel pertugio che abbiamo già
creato con un coltellino con pure delle
forbici
andiamo a riempire di formaggio e
guanciale esplodere prima di passare
alla colata di crema al formaggio un
pochino in pieno stile profiterol
andremo a comporre la nostra
meravigliosa sontuosa e soprattutto
opulenta e scenografica montagna di
pigne partiamo subito ragazzi consiglio
personale per rendere la bella stabile
aiutatevi con un pochino di crema che di
avanzata che fa tipo cemento e piazzate
lì prima tutti quanti nella base e poi
pian piano a salire tipo grande ziggurat
vogliamo parlarne pesa un quintale
ma possiamo parlarne una testa è più
grande della testa e tu hai un testone e
norme tu sei pronto non ancora tu sei
pronto da casa
metti un like se pronto fammelo sentire
che se sei pronto nemici sono pronto
oppure iscriviti questo è pronto a
scrive qua sotto si sono pronto lo sa
che restiamo grossissimo devo fare la
stessa identica creano che ho fatto
prima con la stessa procedura solo che
questa volta metterò metà dose di
ferrari gran knicks in modo che possa
scendere e farmi quell'effetto capito di
glassa la creano di latte pronta metà
dose 100 grammi quello di una bustina
eccola la lavoro la lavoro siamo pronti
enrico per il momento il momento è
regolata
[Musica]
c'è veramente qualcosa da commentare il
rigo o forse come davanti più grandi
miracoli bisogna rimanere in silenzio né
ammirazione questo è il mio profitterol
salato con crema di formaggio se pensi
che questa cosa che tutti i porti a
tavole persone ma non è il momento del
dolce tu gli dici no questo il momento
di mixarli tutti quanti col mixologist
di ferrari gran mix questo è salato e
daria del momento di assaggiarlo a
riposo alla vostra
ti prego io non dico niente allora io
prendo forcone il forcone e soprattutto
un pezzo formaggio sissiko perché sono
un fan capisci cosa arriva clamoroso è
delicatissimo
no non lo so juncker altri vabbè ma
vogliono di quelli sopra quanto è buono
facciamo fare un giro ad assaggi abba le
persone con tridentini per vedere le
loro reazioni indovinate chi è la prima
persona ad assaggiare grande chiana
ma ragazzi sono bellissimi
anche alla soddisfatta di una ricetta il
prossimo concorrente è la mia macchina e
la mina sing sing a secco secco ma
quanto ci venite sono di sicuro e
ludopate io faccio soprattutto la cafona
che vi giuro che vale la pena provarlo è
stato un esperimento non potevo pensare
che visse questa roba qui è il prossimo
concorrente è che mi ha chiesto di
imboccare mostra rock
giammario è buonissimo bene da un altro
non ci sono ragazzi scusate è il motivo
del colosso valenza scassa già tutti
perché sono orgogliosa buona primo sissi
ma bravo successo è l'ultima non me
posizione ma anche per prima valentina
le persone orribili vola vola
l'aeroplanino vola vola all'aeroplanino
napolissimo posta morbidezze
scioglievolezza l'hai fatta tu il
sottoscritto tutto quanto documentato in
video per una volta andrò a vedere un
video
missing non vedo l'ora che anche tu ne
faccia qualcuno vale dai ragazzi siamo
arrivati alla fine di questo video spero
che vi sia piaciuto per la prima volta
un esperimento va non al cento per cento
ma supera le aspettative ti giuro che
non è perché ci stanno a pagare
posso dirlo di giura che non è perché
sponsorizzato avrei detto un'altra cosa
provatelo perché buoni sì ma anzi
leviamoci questa pregiudizio che abbiamo
nelle cose normali che credere io ci
metto la faccia
a parte gli scherzi bomba è il motivo
per cui ho chiesto a tutti quanti di
assaggiarlo perché buono buono buono
buono sono molto soddisfatto di questo
esperimento se volete farlo anche voi i
bignè effettivamente potrebbero fare un
pochino di paura magari ne so potreste
anche prenderle già fatti quelli che a
volte vendono alcune pasticcerie o anche
in busta e mi raccomando seguite la
ricetta perché sa se scatto
io ringrazio ancora per ali g per aver
sponsorizzato questo video ringrazio
tutti quanti voi che ci avete seguito mi
raccomando come sempre iscrivetevi
metteteci un bel pò le censure
soprattutto lasciate un commento di guri
alla fine un bacio grande ci vediamo
quel prossimo video ciao
[Musica]